gwen calls the heart is officially
filming season nine
and the cast is wasting no time sharing
candid snaps
straight from the hope valley set i love
our sweet little town of pope valley and
i'm just
very grateful every day that i go to
work i feel very grateful that i get to
do this thing that i love
with people i love erin graco shared
this stunning image to her instagram
dressed as her character elizabeth
thorton enjoying a moment on the outdoor
set
and check this out show director peter
deluise shared this pic
on twitter it's elizabeth and mounting
nathan grant's first scene together in
the new season
judging by the look on elizabeth's face
things may be
a little awkward since elizabeth ended
things with the mountie
and decided to pursue a courtship with
the saloon owner lucas bouchard
instead nathan i do love you but i'm not
in love with you i'm just so sorry
you're all that matters you're all
that's important
thank you for waiting for me
chris mcnally who plays lucas posted
this shot hanging out on set at a
produce stand
dressed to impress per usual but back to
erin she also had some fun getting ready
in the hair and makeup trailer
alongside her co-star and friend pascal
hutton
i think it's really exciting speaking of
rosemary
here's your first look at the new
editor-in-chief of the town newspaper
alongside her husband lee coulter played
by kevin smith
deloise shared the pick on twitter but
he didn't stop there
he also posted this image of rosemary
and elizabeth's first scene together
in season nine looks like they're having
a somewhat serious conversation
we'll just see we'll see what happens
but off screen the cast is known to keep
things light
case in point photobomb check out the
cultures crashing a beautiful
canfield family moment yep there's
joseph
minnie angela and cooper delouise also
shared this pic of joseph getting some
work done
on a car and here's angela doing what
she does best play piano
it's been a really good year so far just
being in hope valley and with around the
other actors
meanwhile here's some more snaps to hold
you over
faith and molly smiling ear to ear fiona
working on her driving skills
and here are newlyweds florence and ned
looks like ned is staying busy in the
mercantile and putting
robert to work i'm just excited to see
where we go from here
martin cummins who plays henry gowan is
also back
so is jack wagner who couldn't wait to
board his flight to get back to work
thank you so much for the love and
support i'm blown away that
this is still continuing beyond grateful
hope you're all having a great safe
summer and i will keep you posted
to behind the scenes hopefully really
funny stuff
from this season of when calls to heart
e.t will be with when calls the heart
season 9
every step of the way but to hold you
over here's what aaron
kevin and chris told us in may about
their wishes
for the next chapter i am really
interested
in figuring out what the friendship is
like between elizabeth and nathan
we talked a lot about how exciting it'll
be to get to bring
lucas into the little thornton family
and see what that is like
i'm looking forward to exploring the
relationship farther with
between lucas and elizabeth i kind of
think that it might be fun
on a personal level for lucas who has
always
done quite well financially to maybe run
into some trouble
and see what it looks like when
everything is taken away
i think for sure we'll see you know
nathan's bond with
ally grow that kind of comedy you know
of this guy raising a daughter now as a
father figure with no
female input i'm also interested to see
what nathan and elizabeth are going to
do going forward he's
totally accepting of her happiness but
there is a connection that they have
it's not just gonna go away and it'll be
interesting to just to see how
how this goes forward